[Musique]
si vous deviez revivre une époque je
choisirais laquelle d'après histoire
c'est que je suis encore avec ma femme
cher monsieur dream votre fils et moi
serions très honoré de vous offrir à
soirée de votre choix
dans le cadre des voyageurs du temps
concernant l'époque vous avez une dès le
16 mai 74
bonjour de ski drummond
ce jour là je suis un contre une
personne que
que j'aimais beaucoup
bien parisien est sans club
on vous dit que vous organiser des
soirées sur mesure c'est pas seulement
de la pure je sais que tout est faux
mais c'est pas désagréable
elle revient quand elle n'est pas censée
revenir fait ce sont des comédies
mademoiselle
j'ai pas ce qui vous attends je sais pas
ce qui va se passer
le à fond
je prends comme une chanson vous ai
demandé quel âge vous d'accord et vous
18 a carrément pts ont convié pourquoi
se priver alors les jeunes course r
normands bien visible